noch schneller als erwartet hier Stefan
Kulle nämlich jetzt haben wir einen sehr
interessanten Punkt der Bundestag der
befasst sich nämlich jetzt damit wie die
Geschäftsordnung des Bundestages
auszulegen ist so hintergrund ist dass
die afd-fraktion ja nach wie vor kein
bundestagsvizepräsidenten oder ein
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin stellt weil
keiner oder keine der Kandidatinnen
bisher die erforderliche Mehrheit
erhalten hat jetzt hat die afd-fraktion
versucht dass sie mehrere Kandidaten in
einzelnen Wahlgängen aufstellen kann hat
das durch den Ausschuss prüfen lassen
und darüber wird hier jetzt informiert
und debattiert es steht am Rednerpult
Johannes Fechner für die SPD-Fraktion
eben nur vorgenommen werden wenn auch
das entsprechende Vertrauen besteht und
wenn hier nun jemand ins Amt kommt der
möglicherweise nur ganz wenige Stimmen
bekommen hat was die Folge ihrer
Tricksereien wären dann ist dieses
Vertrauensverhältnis eben nicht gegeben
und auch daran können Sie sehen dass
unsere auslegungsentscheidung richtig
und notwendig war liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und ihr Vorschlag ist auch ein ganz
klarer Verstoß gegen das freie Mandat
wir wollen hier entscheiden wer wie in
dieses wichtige Amt des Vizepräsidenten
der Vizepräsidentin kommt das wollen sie
nicht die Geschäftsordnung sieht das
aber ausdrücklich vor und auf deswegen
ist es richtig wie wir hier entschieden
haben denn gehen jetzt einmal durch was
sie im Detail hätten wollen sie haben in
der letzten Sitzung als wir dieses Thema
hier hatten sogar gleich drei Kandidaten
ins Rennen geschickt also offensichtlich
vertrauen Sie den Personen die sie nicht
benannt haben wollten sie drei Personen
ins Rennen schicken den wir an wir
hätten das gemacht eine Person hätte
zehn Stimmen bekommen die nächste 20 und
die nächste die letzte Person 30 Stimmen
dann wäre hier jemand in dieses wichtige
Amt des Vizepräsident mit 30 Stimmen
dieses Hauses gekommen das kann es ja
wohl offensichtlich nicht sein und
deswegen ist es gut dass wir diese
auslegungsentscheidung hier getroffen
haben meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren wir sehen auch einmal mehr an
diesem Vorgang dass es da AFD nicht um
konkrete Politik ihnen geht es nicht
darum die das Leben der Menschen zu
verbessern sondern ihnen geht es vor
allem darum wie sie ihre Leute in posten
hier im Bundestag hießen können das
machen wir aber so nicht mit wir halten
uns hier an die Regelung der
Geschäftsordnung diese Tricks die sie
hier anwenden die werden hier ein Ende
haben liebe meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren beenden wir heute dieses
zehn bestimmt nicht vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit also darf eine Fraktion
für den von ihr zu stellenden
vizepräsidentenposten im zweiten
Wahlgang mehrere Bewerber vorschlagen
oder nicht der Ausschuss für Wahlprüfung
und Immunität hat mit den Stimmen der
Fraktion SPD Bündnis 90 Grüne FDP CDU
und Linke entschieden nein die AFD hatte
das nämlich beantragt jetzt spricht für
die AFD Stefan Brandner herr Präsident
Genosse Fechner der
Bundestagsvizepräsident und die
Alternative für Deutschland eine never
ending story hier im Parlament und das
ist auch gut so denn damit gerät nicht
in Vergessenheit wie sie von den
Altparteien sich seit über fünf Jahren
das Gesetz dass ihr selbstgemachtes
geschäftsordnungsrecht wie sie es
vorsätzlich brechen und ihre eigenen
Beschlüsse missachten seit über fünf
Jahren weigern sich hier fast alle von
den Altparteien wie bockige Kinder der
alternative den
bundestagsvizepräsidenten zu verweigert
und das ist Rechtsbruch pur meine Damen
und Herren lassen Sie mal andere
sprechen ich zitiere bei der Frage wie
viele Vizepräsidenten ist im Bundestag
geben soll besteht eigentlich Konsens
der sich in der Geschäftsordnung findet
dort ist nämlich geregelt dass jede
Fraktion einen Vizepräsidenten stellt
der Gedanke der Repräsentation soll die
Zahl der Vizepräsidenten bestellen
bestimmen Zitat Ende das sagte Jürgen
Norbert Röttgen von der CDU am
18.10.2005 interessant auch am selben
Tag am
18.10.2015 da redete Olaf Scholz und der
stimmte diesen Aussagen von Röttgen ich
zitiere vollinhaltlich Zitat Ende zu
wobei ich davon ausgehe dass Olaf Scholz
dass inzwischen vergessen hat bereits zu
gab es darüber Debatten vor zehn Jahren
vorher am 10 November 1994 auch eine
Debatte zu dem Thema der äußerte sich
Jürgen Rüttgers danach Ministerpräsident
von NRW genauso eindeutig damals ging es
um die Grünen die einen
bundestagsvizepräsidenten wollten und
die Grünen wurden damals von der CSU
bezeichnet als Zitat eine Partei der
Macht Opportunisten und weltfremde
ökosozialisten Zitat Ende da war die CSU
schon 1994 wesentlich weiter als Herr
Söder heute und trotzdem haben die
Grünen einen
bundestagsvizepräsidenten erhalten man
sieht jahrzehntelange parlamentarische
Praxis treten sie seit fünf Jahren in
die Tonne meine Damen und Herren fünf
Millionen Bürger haben die Alternative
für Deutschland bei der letzten
Bundestagswahl gewählt weil sie eine
Partei wollten und bekommen haben die
wie keine andere in Deutschland und in
diesem Parlament für Freiheit Demokratie
und Grundrechte steht und kämpft und
diese fünf Millionen Wähler Gren sie
seit fünf Jahren aus dem Präsidium des
Deutschen Bundestages aus Anlass für die
Debatte heute ist die völlig absurde
Auslegung der
Geschäftsordnungsausschusses völlig im
Gegensatz zu dem was in der
Geschäftsordnung geregelt ist und wenn
sie uns vorwerfen Herr Fechner Genosse
Fechner wenn sie uns vorwerfen dass wir
mehrere Wahlvorschläge gemacht haben das
nennt man Demokratie demokratie lebt von
Auswahl wir wollten mehrere
Wahlvorschläge machen sie lehnen alles
in Bausch und Bogen ab meine Damen und
Herren interessant auch am 10.11 1994
Peter Struck nachzulesen auf Seite 10
des Protokolls unserer Meinung er sagt
genauso wie die AFD das sieht aber nicht
gesagt aber er würde heute sagen genauso
wie die AFD dass sie genauso hat das
Petra struppeta Struck im 1994 gesehen
und auch der gestern verstorbene Werner
Schulz den wir heute morgen gedacht
haben auch der hat das 1994
unterstützt also meine Damen und Herren
wenn sie schon uns nicht glauben wollen
handeln sie wenigstens so wie Petra
später Struck und Werner Schulz ist
gemacht hätten stimmen Sie dem zu was
wir wollen begehen Sie keine weiteren
Fehler sie haben gleich die Chance dazu
der Wahlgang wird eröffnet gehen sie
raus und wählen Sie unsere Kandidaten
von der AFD und wir sind zufrieden mit
diesem Parlament und sie brechen nicht
weiter geschäftsordnungsrecht vielen
Dank
ja die AFD schickt heute einen weiteren
Kandidaten ins renn Stefan proczka bitte
sein für die AFD übrigens hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht allerdings
gerade zwei Klagen im März diesen Jahres
der AFD abgewiesen wo es genau darum
ging den Bundestags viel zu posten zu
erstreiten da sagte das
Bundesverfassungsgericht dass die Klage
offensichtlich unbegründet sei die Wahl
sei frei eine Pflicht zur Wahl eines
bestimmten Kandidaten gäbe es eben nicht
Daniela Ludwig jetzt für die Union
ja es ist richtig
die Stellvertreter sollen und müssen
nach meinem Dafürhalten und hat der
Kollege Dr Fechner absolut richtig
gesprochen einer breiten Mehrheit des
Hauses entsprechend und auch von einer
breiten Mehrheit des Hauses gewählt
werden worüber wir hier debattieren es
aber nicht die Frage
die sie bisher auch nicht erfüllt haben
findet einer der AFD Kandidaten eine
Mehrheit oder nicht sondern wir
debattieren hier das was für
Feinschmecker darum ob wenn in einem
ersten Wahlgang ein Kandidat von ihnen
nicht gewählt wird sie einen weiteren
Kandidaten zu diesem ersten Kandidaten
dazu im zweiten Wahlgang schicken dürfen
und da gibt es eine und das ist aber in
ihrer Rede ehrlicherweise nur am Rande
erwähnt worden und da gibt es relativ
klare Auslegung die unser erster
Ausschuss auch bestätigt und nochmals
getroffen hat nein das geht eben nicht
sie können einen neuen Kandidaten
schicken aber keinen weiteren und darum
dreht sich diese Debatte heute ich weiß
es ist müßig und auch juristisch immer
nur die Fußnote darum geht es und nicht
um die Frage wird hier sozusagen das
rechte AFD auf einen Stellvertreter mit
Füßen getreten darum geht es heute
ausdrücklich nämlich nicht und wir haben
im Ausschuss sehr eindeutig nochmals
festgehalten das konkurrierende bedingte
oder eben parallele Vorschläge im
zweiten Wahlgang nicht zulässig sind
warum weil das sozusagen die
Einschränkung des freien Mandats nein
nicht weil wir es nicht wollen Herr
Brantner das sind noch Märchen die sie
hier erzählen sondern weil sie die freie
Entscheidung der Kolleginnen und
Kollegen bei der Wahl zum Stellvertreter
eben einschränken würden und weil
sozusagen dadurch die Wahl eines
Vertreters mit wenigen Stimmen lieber
Herr Fechner damit erzwungen werden
könnte und das ist nicht Sinn einer Wahl
weder wenn jemand ins Wahllokal draußen
geht noch wenn wir hier an unsere
Wahlurnen gehen und wählen das steht
nein so
und deswegen und deswegen haben wir
diese richtige wie ich finde sehr klare
auslegungsentscheidungen unserem
Ausschuss getroffen und ich hoffe sehr
ich hoffe sehr dass es uns in
zukunftigen Wahlgängen zu einem
rechtssicheren Verfahren verhilft dafür
ist nämlich dieser Ausschuss auch
zuständig und ich hoffe sehr dass wir
damit gewährleisten dass das Präsidium
seinen Aufgaben mit einem wohlgemerkt
breiten Rückhalt aus diesem Hohen Haus
nachkommen kann vielen herzlichen Dank
und Daniela Ludwig ist nämlich die
Vorsitzende des Ausschusses für
Wahlprüfung Immunität und
Geschäftsordnungen wo eben solche Sachen
verhandelt werden und wenn es
beispielsweise eben um diese
geschäftsordnungsauslegung geht Jan
Korte jetzt für die Linke der
Parlamentarische Geschäftsführer
und Kollegen sie versuchen das ja hier
im Wochentag einen Vizepräsidentin zu
erzwingen und das funktioniert nicht sie
waren ja bereits in Karlsruhe mit Ihrem
Anliegen beim Bundesverfassungsgericht
und möchte die wie ich finde ja also ist
nicht das neue Deutschland sondern die
FAZ zitieren die hat zu ihren Versuchen
folgendes gesagt zwar gewährt die
Geschäftsordnung allen Fraktionen das
Recht im Präsidium vertreten zu sein wie
das Verfassungsgericht nun aber klar
stellte steht dieses Recht aber unter
einem gewichtigen Vorbehalt nämlich dem
der Wahl das haben sie offenbar nicht
mitbekommen denn sie sind ja angetreten
dass ihr gutes Recht und sie sind ja
halt nicht gewählt worden darüber würde
ich einfach mal nachdenken das ist so
bei einer Wahl und ich als Linker
ich kann das Gefühl nachvollziehen nicht
gewählt zu werden also wir haben da
gewisse Erfahrung gesammelt im Laufe
unserer Geschichte aber so ist das und
ich kann ihnen auch ganz ganz deutlich
sagen er Brandner ganz sicher wird meine
Fraktion niemals irgendein von ihnen
braunen Vögeln wählen das ist ganz
sicher können Sie ganz sicher sein
deswegen haben wir hier nicht nur eine
geschäftsordnungstage sondern wir haben
eine politische Frage hier zu
diskutieren und zu klären und ich würde
mal sagen zum Glück haben wir hier auch
ein Wahlgeheimnis aber wenn ich rede
wenn ich sehe wie sie nehmen wir mal die
ehemalige Vizepräsidentin Claudia Roth
oder Petra Pau diese über die reden wie
sie mit denen hier umgehen wäre ja mal
mein Tipp dass sie die tendenziell eher
glaube ich nicht geschlossen gewählt
haben ja das ist hier gutes Recht das
ist falsch aber es werden sie ja wohl
nicht getan haben und genauso ist es das
Recht von allen anderen dass man von
ihnen auch keinen wählt und dann würde
ich ja mal vielleicht also wenn man also
immer wieder andere noch nicht gewählt
wird ich kenne das aus der Geschichte
dann kann man ja darüber nachdenken ob
er vielleicht mal was ändert und man
könnte überlegen vielleicht liegt das ja
an mir vielleicht sind ja nicht alle
anderen bekloppt sondern ich selber das
könnte das könnte ja sein es könnte
jetzt könnt ihr ja wirklich sein und da
will ich ihn will ich ihnen dann will
ich will ich ihn will ich ihn schon mal
was sagen man darf sie ja nicht wundern
wenn wir den ganzen Tag Nazi Zeug
erzählt dass erfreulicherweise so ist
dass es dafür nicht mal ansatzweise eine
Mehrheit im Bundestag gibt und das wird
auch so bleiben das ist ja die Sachlage
dass die Sachlage mit der wir es hier zu
tun haben und wir werden auf keinen Fall
mitmachen sie haben die gleichen Rechte
wie alle anderen aber das was sie wollen
eine Sonderregelung wollen Sie für sich
haben für ihren braunen Klamauk und das
gibt's halt nicht alles Gute
vielen Dank Herr Rieger Torte damit
schließe ich die Aussprache
Beratung der auslegungsentscheidung des
Ausschusses für Wahlprüfung imitierten
Geschäftsordnung vom 7 November 2022 zur
Auslegung der Geschäftsordnung hier
Benennung zusätzlicher
kandidatinnenkandidaten im zweiten
Wahlgang einer vizepräsidentenwahl durch
die vorschlagsberechtigte Fraktion
hierzu liegt der Bericht des Ausschusses
auf Drucksache 4296 vor wer stimmt für
die auslegungsentscheidung in den
Bericht auf Drucksache 4296 das sind die
regierungsstrale Fraktion cdu/csu und
Linke wer stimmt dagegen das ist die
afd-enthaltung keine damit ist die
Auslegung der Geschäftsordnung
angenommen ich rufe auch die
Tagesordnungspunkte das ist ja deutlich
geworden also
wird der Bundestag wird nicht gestatten
dass es also
für den
vizepräsidentenkosten im zweiten
Wahlgang mehrere Bewerber von einer
Fraktion gibt für dann den darauf
folgenden Wahlgang so jetzt haben wir
noch apropos Wahlen bleiben wir dabei
wir haben nämlich jetzt noch Wahlgänge
und zwar schickt die AFD ein erneut
einen Kandidaten für den Posten des
Vizepräsidenten des Bundestages ins
Rennen und wir hören mal Wolfgang
Kubicki der jetzt die Wahlen aufrufen
wird die Schriftführung Schriftführer
ihre Plätze an den ausgabedischen und an
ihren Ohren einzunehmen mir ist
beschädigt worden das ist bereits der
Fall die Wahlvorschläge liegen auf den
Drucksachen 4153 4154 und 4338 vor auf
den Stimmzetteln sind die Namen der
vorgeschlagenen Kandidatin und
Kandidaten aufgeführt die Wahlen
erfolgen in der abgeordnetenlobby in der
Abgeordneten Lobby erhalten Sie an den
ausgabetischen nach vorzeigen ihres
wahlausweises drei Stimmkarten da die
Wahl des stellvertresente geheim
durchzuführen ist erhalten Sie für diese
Wahl zusätzlich einen passenden
Wahlumschlag alle Stimmzettel sind in
der Wahlkabine anzukreuzen sie können
bei diesen Wahlen auf allen Stimmzetteln
zu dem aufgeführten Kandidatenvorschlag
ein Kreuz bei ja nein oder enthalte mich
machen alles andere macht die Stimme
ungültig der grüne Stimmzettel ist in
den grünen Wahlumschlag zu legen dies
muss in der Kabinen erfolgen für die
beiden weiteren Stimmzettel erhalten Sie
keine Wahlumschläge da sich im offene
Wahlen handelt gewählt ist jeweils wer
die Stimmen der Mehrheit der Mitglieder
des Bundestages auf sich vereint das
heißt wir mindestens 396 Stimmen erhält
ich weise explizit darauf hin dass das
Fotografieren oder Filmen der
ausgefüllten Stimmkarten bei der
geheimen Wahl einen Verstoß gegen das
Wahlgeheimnis darstellt und die Ordnung
und Würde des Hauses verletzt für den
Fall dass ich von solchen Verstößen
gegen das Wahlgeheimnis in dieser
Sitzung oder später Kenntnisse lange
bald ich mir schon jetzt vor
Ordnungsmaßnahmen zu ergreifen
sie haben zur Abgabe ihrer Stimme
Stimmen 60 Minuten Zeit die schleppen
und Schriftführer haben ihre Plätze
eingenommen ich öffne die Wahlen die
Schließung der Wahlen erfolgt um 17 Uhr
so der Bundestag
sehr schnell mit der Ankündigung der
Wahlen deswegen vielleicht noch mal
hinterher geschoben also es wird gewählt
zum einen gibt es ein Kandidaten der AFD
das hatte ich gesagt für das sind Posten
ist bundestagsvizepräsidenten das ist
Stefan proczka den die AFD in zu Rennen
schickt darüber hinaus gibt es eine Wahl
da geht es um das Parlamentarische
Kontrollgremium das ist ja jenes Gremium
was die Nachrichtendienste kontrolliert
auch da hat die AFD bislang keinen
Kandidatin Kandidaten da kandidiert
Martin Hess aber